[Music]
I started as a dancer so this is very
exciting for me well her fans are
excited too as Gina Rodriguez shows off
her dance moves and her new baby with
hubby Joe Lo Cicero he's magical he's
really Next Level my partner he's
definitely the better half the actress
proves she's the queen of multitasking
grooving on the dance floor with her
baby boy Charlie strapped to her chest
if Gina's dance partner looks familiar
it's because he is it's Sasha Farber a
pro on Dancing With the Stars
this is way better than anything
Gina shares in the caption yes I am
breastfeeding and all that hard work's
got Sasha impressed he reposted the clip
to his story and praised Gina writing
multitasking and crushing the game at
the same time there was just layers of
blessings the post marks the first time
Gina shared her little bundle of joy
with the world it's really magical I'm
building some beef I'm a baby Gina says
in her caption that her little guy is
one of her three favorite things the
others dancing and her new TV series not
dead yet what no fine it's good let's
just keep moving on building organs and
memorizing lives is a very interesting
Duo I will tell you mom and dad first
shared the good news last year posting
this touching Montage that ends with
Gina holding a pregnancy test
anyone can one you
but
love hits different
when someone actually values you there
goes my
heartbeat me and my husband always make
space for each other and we didn't
really have honeymoon and I think in
this industry we can be led by the
industry versus leading Our Lives first
so I'm making space for the things that
matter Gina and Joe tied the knot in
2019 the couple first crossed paths when
Joe appeared on her show Jane the Virgin
oh my God I forgot to cancel this Ripper
we met on Jane and then six months later
we saw each other in the gym on said it
was like Hey lovely to meet you but you
have to be you can't cross that line no
right no I'm not like hey maybe my
trailer yeah you know if you want
another job
never I would never know what he is
hopefully Gina got the same perks as she
did while playing pregnant Jane in 2015.
and like did you were you ever like
walking around like the the whole set of
yours is fully payment all the time all
the time walk away lunch so I'd go like
you know to Chipotle yeah Chipotle got a
long line yo you know what I'm saying
Chipotle you go into has a long line
yeah but if you're pregnant
I'm really hungry we're really hungry I
think the women and making babies is the
most magical thing oh this is how
everybody should feel just so you know
for all the women out there
[Music]
thank you